مباريات في البلاي ستيشن والبيبي فوت
لاسبانيا قبل مواجهه المغرب انقسامات بين
لاعبي المنتخب الالماني بشان التغطيهم
البرازيلي ادريانو يطلق زوجته بعد اربعه
24 يوما من الزواج هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
اليوم من معسكر المنتخب الاسباني حيث
استغل اللاعبون موجوده العاب فيها لقضاء
اوقات مسليه عاليهم يخففون ضغوطات مواجهه
المغرب غدا ضمن مباريات ثمن النهائي
المونديال البلاي ستيشن
حماسيه بين لاعبي المتدور وتاهل المنتخب
الاسباني الى الدور الثاني باحتلاله وصافه
المجموعه الخامسه
المجموعه السادسه بسبع نقاط
كشف موقع سبورت باي بال البريطاني بان
حركه تغطيه الفم التي قام بها لاعبوا
المنتخب الالماني في البطوله قد احدثت
انقسام حادا داخل غرفه تغيير الملابس بسبب
عدم موافقه بعض اللاعبين عليها وبحسب
المنشور لم يكن كل لاعب موافقا على
الايمان قبل مباراه اليابان بل ان بعضهم
كان قلقا من انها قد تحدث مشاكل في الفريق
ووضع لاعب المنتخب الالماني اياديهم على
افواههم خلال سوره الرسميه قبيله مباراه
اليابان احتجاجا على رفضه لقائد فريقهم
بارتداء اشارتي حب واحد
تداول مواقع السوشال ميديا اليوم خبر
انفصال البرازيلي ادريانو عن زوجته بعد 24
يوما فقط من زواجهما بسبب المونديال
الانباء الصحفيه تؤكد ان السبب الخلاف
يرجعوا الى زياره نجم المنتخب البرازيلي
السابق لاصدقائه لاصدقائه في مدينه ريو
لمشاهده مباراه منتخب بلاده امام سويسرا
في المونديال وعلى ذمه المنشور وبعد عوده
ادريانو الى المنزل بعد يومين من غيابه
اشتبك مع زوجته حول مكان وجودته وهو امر
دفع الى توقف الثنائي عن متابعه بعضهم
البعض على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بل
وحذف الزوجه ميكالا لجميع الصور السابقه
لها مع ادريانو
الختام مع الشماغ العربي او ما يعرف
بالغتره الخليجيه الذي اصبح حاضرا وبقوه
بين زوار مونديال قطر الاجانب صحيفه اكدت
ان الغتره الخليجيه باتت سما مميزه
للمونديال وتحديدا الملونه بالوان
المنتخبات المشاركه في البطوله وبحسب
المنشور بين زوار قاموا بشراء الشماغ
كوسيله لاظهار الاحترام للتقاليد العربيه
فيما اشار اخرون بانها بطريقه جيده
للتبريد
[موسيقى]